♪
>> IS IT DOMESTIC EXTREMISM FOR
A PARENT TO ADVOCATE FOR THEIR
CHILD'S BEST TRNKTS NO I WOULD
NOT DESCRIBE DOMESTIC EXTREMISM.
>> IS EXPRESSING ONE'S VIEW
HARASSMENT.
>> AS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
MEMORANDUM MADE QUITE CLEAR
SPIRITED DEBATE IS WELCOME WHEN
AND IF.
WHEN ANY SITUATION TURNS TO
VIOLENCE, THEN THAT IS THE
APPROPRIATE ROLE OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO ADDRESS IT.
>> YOU ARE ATTEMPTING TO
INTIMIDATE THEM.
YOU ARE ATTEMPTING TO SILENCE
THEM.
YOU ARE ATTEMPTING TO INTERFERE
WITH THEIR RIGHT AS PARENTS AND,
YES, WITH THEIR RIGHTS AS
VOTERS.
THIS IS WRONG.
THIS IS DANGEROUS.
>> Shannon: SPEAK WITH OUR PANEL
AND SEE WHAT THEY THINK HAROLD
FORD JUNIOR FORMER TENNESSEE
CONGRESSMAN AND CEO OF
EMPOWERMENT AND INCLUSION
CAPITAL.
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY EDITOR AT "THE
FEDERALIST" AND GUY BENSON HOST
OF THE GUY BENSON SHOW ON FOX
NEWS RADIO.
GREAT TO SEE ALL OF YOU ALL.
I WILL START WITH THE AGREEMENT
POINT I THINK WE ALL AGREE
ANYTHING THAT CROSSES INTO
VIOLENCE IS UNACCEPTABLE IN MANY
PLACES.
IT'S CRIMINAL AND ILLEGAL BUT
THIS IS WHAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT NOW TODAY FROM THE DOJ,
THE MEMO SAYS THREATS AGAINST
PUBLIC SERVANTS ARE NOT ONLY
ILLUSTRATE LEGAL THEY RUN
COUNTER TO OUR NATION'S CORE
VALUES.
THOSE WHO DEDICATE THEIR TIME
AND ENERGY TO ENSURE CHILDREN
RECEIVE PROPER EDUCATION IN A
SAFE ENVIRONMENT DESERVE TO BE
ABLE TO DO THEIR WORK WITHOUT
FEAR FOR THEIR SAFETY.
MOLLIE, WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF IT.
>> THIS IS AMAZING WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND FBI
WILL DO AND WHAT THEY WON'T DO.
LAST YEAR WE HAD A SERIES OF
VIOLENT RIOTS THAT COST
$2 BILLION WORTH OF DAMAGE.
KILLED DOZENS OF PEOPLE.
ATTACKED THE WHITE HOUSE,
FEDERAL COURTHOUSES, POLICE
PRECINCTS, HUNDREDS OF AMERICAN
BUSINESSES.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
AND FBI WERE BASICALLY NOWHERE
TO BE FOUND.
YOU MENTIONED EARLIER TONIGHT
ABOUT HOW LITTLE THEY DID WITH
THE GYMNAST, COACH HAD YOU
CREDIBLE REPORTS OF HIM RAPING
PEOPLE AND FBI WAS NOWHERE TO BE
FOUND.
YET, HERE, WHEN PARENTS VERY
REASONABLY ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
ALL SORTS OF THINGS HAPPENING IN
THEIR SCHOOL WHETHER IT'S
TEACHING THEIR STUDENTS,
TEACHING THEIR OWN CHILDREN TO
HATE OTHER PEOPLE, BASED ON
THEIR RACE OR TO THINK THAT
THEY'RE VICTIMS WHO CAN NEVER
SUCCEED BECAUSE OF THEIR RACE,
OR THAT THE COUNTRY IS
SYSTEMATICALLY RACE NIST A WAY
THAT IS IRREDEEMABLE, OF COURSE
PARENTS ARE GOING TO WANT TO
WEIGH IN ON THAT.
AND TO INTIMIDATE THEM AND TO
DECLARE WAR ON AMERICAN PARENTS
PARTICULARLY WHEN THE FBI AND
DOJ HAVE BEEN NOWHERE TO BE
FOUND ON ISSUES WHERE THEY
ACTUALLY WERE NEEDED IS JUST
UNCONSCIONABLE.
A POLITICIZATION OF OUR DOJ THAT
IS NOT TENABLE.
>> Shannon: SO I WANT TO PLAY A
LITTLE BIT FROM A BOARD MEETING.
ONE OF THESE SCHOOL BOARD
MEETINGS THAT WE KEEP HEARING SO
MUCH ABOUT AND A LITTLE BIT MORE
OF THE DEBATE ON THIS ISSUE.
[SHOUTING]
[CHANTING NO MORE MASKS.
[.
>> GOING TO ADJOURN THIS
MEETING.
>> THERE IS NO PLACE FOR
PHYSICAL VIOLENCE ANYWHERE FOR
ANYONE.
NO PLACE FOR PARENTS SPEAKING
THEIR MIND AND CARING ABOUT
THEIR KIDS' EDUCATION AND THEIR
FUTURES.
>> JUSTICE SHOULD NOT BE USED TO
ATTACK A GROUP OF PEOPLE
EXPRESSING THEIR OPINIONS AT
SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS.
THAT'S POLITICAL SPEECH THAT
NEEDS TO BE PROTECTED.
>> Shannon: IT'S GOTTEN HEATED,
HAROLD, IT WORRY THIS MAY CHILL
OR ATTEMPT TO CHILL SOME
PARENTS' SPEECH.
>> FIRST, THANKS FOR HAVING ME
ON.
I HOPE IT DOESN'T CHILL ANYONE
FROM SHARING THEIR VIEWS.
WE SHOULD ALL REMEMBER THAT MOST
SCHOOL BOARDS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
ARE ELECTED THERE ARE SOME THAT
ARE CONTROLLED BY CITY
GOVERNMENT OR THE MAYORS OF THE
COUNTY EXECUTIVES IN THOSE
AREAS.
BUT I THINK THE INSTANCES WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT HERE ARE ELECTED
MEMBERS OF THE SCHOOL BOARD.
WE, AS VOTERS, HAVE EVERY RIGHT
TO VOTE THEM OUT OF OFFICE.
THAT'S THE ULTIMATE POWERFUL
EXPRESSION OF WHETHER WE AGREE
WITH OR DISAGREE WITH.
I THINK WE HAVE NOW GOTTEN TO A
VERY DELICATE BALANCE HERE.
I WOULD SIDE WITH MOLLIE ON A
LOT OF WHAT SHE SAID AND
DISAGREE WITH SOME.
WHENEVER YOU THREATEN SOMEONE,
WHO IS IN PUBLIC OFFICE,
WHENEVER YOU TRY TO EXACT
VIOLENCE ON SOMEONE TO IMPOSE
YOUR POLITICAL VIEW, WHETHER
IT'S A VIEW I AGREE WITH OR
DISAGREE WITH, THAT'S WRONG.
AND I THINK WHERE THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS TRYING TO ACHIEVE,
TRYING TO ACHIEVE HERE IS TO SAY
THAT THE VIOLENCE AND THE
THREATS ARE WRONG.
ALL OF THE DISSENT, ALL OF THE
DEBATE, WE SHOULD WELCOME THAT.
WHATEVER SIDE OF THE WALL YOU
FALL ON ON ANY OF THESE ISSUES
THAT ARE BEING DEBATED.
I DON'T THINK ANY PERSON, BE
THEY CONSERVATIVE OR LIBERAL, BE
THEY DEMOCRAT OR REPUBLICAN, IF
THEY ARE AN ELECTED OFFICIAL,
THE WAY YOU REALLY ACT AGAINST
AN ELECTED OFFICIAL IS TO VOTE
THAT PERSON OUT OF OFFICE.
NOT TO THREATEN THEM WITH
VIOLENCE OR THREATEN THEIR
FAMILY WITH RETRIBUTION.
>> Shannon: MEANTIME, GUY, ARE A
LOT OF FOLKS WILL POINT TO LOCAL
ORDINANCES, STATE LAWS THAT DO
BAN AND PROHIBIT THREATS AND
VIOLENCE ALREADY.
THEY ARE ON THE PECULIARS.
>> YEAH, THERE IS NO PLACE FOR
VIOLENCE.
THERE IS NO PLACE FOR THREATS.
THERE'S NO PLACE FOR GOING TO
SOMEONE'S PRIVATE HOME OR THEIR
FAMILY'S HOME, FOR EXAMPLE.
THERE'S NO PLACE FOR HOUNDING OR
CHASING SOMEONE INTO A BATHROOM
WHILE FILMING THEM TO PICK
ANOTHER EXAMPLE AT COMPLETE
RANDOM THERE ARE CERTAIN BRIGHT
LINES IN OUR POLITICS THAT
SHOULD NOT BE CROSSED.
IF THEY'RE CROSSED, ESPECIALLY
ON THE CRIMINAL SIDE, I HAVE NO
PROBLEM WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
GETTING INVOLVED, PARTICULARLY
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND THE THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND THE
FBI NEEDS TO BE INVOLVED IN THIS
POTENTIAL PROBLEM AT ALL.
I FEEL LIKE IF THERE ARE PEOPLE
ISSUING THREATS OR ENGAGE IN
VIOLENCE THAT IS SOMETHING FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO DEAL WITH.
OF COURSE, IT'S TOTALLY
UNACCEPTABLE AND SERIOUS.
BUT I WORRY ABOUT WITH THE FEDS
GETTING INVOLVED AND THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL FROM THIS
ADMINISTRATION SORT OF WADING
INTO THIS IS THAT THIS IS AN
ATTEMPT TO DELEGITIMIZE THE
LEGITIMATE COMPLAINTS THAT MANY
PARENTS HAVE WITH SCHOOL BOARDS,
WITH TEACHERS UNIONS AND OTHERS
AND TO SAY WELL, BECAUSE THERE
MIGHT BE SOME THREAT AND SOME
VIOLENCE ELSEWHERE, NOW THIS IS
A FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT MATTER
SO YOU BETTER, YOU KNOW, CONTAIN
YOURSELF, RESTRAIN YOURSELF.
MAYBE THINK TWICE ABOUT SHOWING
UP AND MAKING YOUR VOICE HEARD
AT A SCHOOL BOARD MEETING, FOR
EXAMPLE.
I THINK THAT THAT IS SIGNIFICANT
OVERREACH.
>> Shannon: I WANT TO TOUCH ON
THE FACEBOOK WHISTLEBLOWER TODAY
AS WELL.
PLAY A LITTLE BIT OF THE CLIPS
FROM HER TODAY AND GET A QUICK
COMMENT FROM EACH OF YOU.
>> FACEBOOK'S PRODUCTS HARM
CHILDREN, SOW DIVISION AND
WEAKEN DEMOCRACY.
THE COMPANY'S LEADERSHIP KNOWS
THOUSAND MAKE INSTAGRAM AND
SAFER WON'T MAKE THE CHANGES BUT
ASTRONOMICAL PROFITS BEFORE
PEOPLE.
PEOPLE BULLIED ON INSTAGRAM IT
FOLLOWS THEM HOME.
THE LAST TIME THEY SEE AT NIGHT
SOMEONE BEING CRUEL TO.
THEY FACEBOOK IS STUCK IN A
FEEDBACK LOOP THEY CAN'T GET OUT
OF.
THEY HAVE BEEN HIDING THIS
INFORMATION BECAUSE THEY FEEL
TRAPPED.
THEY NEED TO ADMIT THEY DID
SOMETHING WRONG AND THEY NEED TO
HELP SOLVING THESE PROBLEM.
THAT'S WHAT MORAL BANKRUPTCY IS.
>> Shannon: WORK OUR WAY BACK,
GUY, ARE HAROLD AND MOLLIE.
>> FACEBOOK HAS SOME REAL
SERIOUS QUESTIONS TO ANSWER.
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY ARE
BOTH APPROPRIATE ENDS HERE.
HOWEVER, DO I HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW MUCH OF THIS
MIGHT BE POLITICALLY MOTIVATED
AND WHEN WE START WADING TO THE
MISINFORMATION WARS, THAT'S
WHERE I GET A LITTLE BIT
NERVOUS.
>> Shannon: HAROLD?
>> THIS WHISTLEBLOWER HER
TESTIMONY WAS PLAIN-SPOKEN,
STUNNINGLY COMPELLING, AND,
FRANKLY, IT PUTS FACEBOOK ON ITS
EDGES.
AND THE OTHER THING THAT
FACEBOOK HAS TO WORRY ABOUT,
THIS IS BIPARTISAN.
THAT ENTIRE COMMITTEE,
REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRAT ALIKE,
ALL SIDE NOT ONLY OVERSIGHT BUT
NEW REGULATIONS.
>> THERE IS EVERY REASON TO BE
SUSPICIOUS ABOUT THIS.
THIS IS DEMOCRATIC INFORMATION
OPERATION BEING RUN BY A
DEMOCRATIC P.R. FIRM.
WE ALREADY KNOW THAT TECH
COMPANIES HAVE BEEN COLLUDING
WITH THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY TO
SUPPRESS CONSERVATIVE SPEECH AND
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE AND
PEOPLE NEED TO BE ON GUARD ABOUT
WHAT THEY'RE BEI